good afternoon
we are here as team Europe
we want to mark an important milestone
in the relationship between Tunisia and
the European Union
Tunisia is a partner that we value very
much in the European Union and this is
demonstrated by the three of us being
here in Tunis today
and by the kind hospitality we received
and the good discussions with President
Syed
with Tunisia we share much more than
Geographic proximity we share a history
since 2011 the European Union has been
supporting tunisia's journey of
democracy it's a long sometimes
difficult Road
but these difficulties can be overcome
and against the backdrop of global
uncertainties it is in our common
interest to strengthen our relationship
and to invest in stability and
prosperity
and this is why we are here
and this is why we're working with
Tunisia on a comprehensive package
this package has five pillars
the first pillar is economic development
we will support Tunisia to strengthen
its economy
the European commission is considering
macro financial assistance as soon as
the necessary agreement is found
and we are ready to mobilize up to 900
million euros for this purpose of macro
financial assistance
as an immediate step
we could provide an additional
up to 150 million euros in budget
support right now
the second pillar is investment and
trade
the European Union is tunisia's biggest
foreign investor and trading partner and
we propose to go further
we would like to modernize our current
Trade Agreement
there's much potential to create jobs
and boost growth here in Tunisia
for example an important focus is for
our investments is the digital sector
we already have a good basis
our Flagship program project the Medusa
submarine cable will link the two sides
of the Mediterranean
the middle those are cable is bringing
high-speed Broadband to the region a
real digital bridge that by 2025 will
connect 11 countries around the
Mediterranean
together with the European Investment
Bank we're investing 150 million euros
in this project
the biggest area
for investment we see in energy
and this is our third pillar energy is a
win-win area
Tunisia is looking to harness its
tremendous potential of renewable energy
and the new European Union needs
reliable energy suppliers of clean
energy as we are electrifying our entire
economy
thus we need to invest in our
infrastructure
so that Tunisia can export clean energy
to Europe and produce the clean energy
for the country itself
and here an important milestone in this
term journey is the element
interconnector
this is an undersea electrical
electricity cable linking Tunisia to
Italy
the European Union is investing more
than 300 million euros in the helmet
interconnector this is great news for
Tunisia and Europe and in the Autumn we
will propose to organize together an
investment forum for private Capital to
bring more of this private investment to
tunisia's renewable sector including
hydrogen
now this is a description of different
projects to put all this in a roadmap we
are now working on a memorandum of
understanding unrenewable energy with
Tunisia
the first pillar is migration
we both have a vast interest in Breaking
the cynical business model of Smugglers
and traffickers
it is horrible to see how they
deliberately risk human lives for profit
so we will work together on an
anti-smaggling operational partnership
and we will support Tunisia with border
management
this year the European Union will
provide 100 million euros to Tunisia for
Border management but also for search
and rescue and anti-smaggling and return
the objective is to have a holistic
approach to migration policy rooted in
the respect for human rights
finally last but certainly not least the
fifth and very important pillar is about
People to People contacts
Tunisia has a very young and vibrant
population and we should do everything
to bring people together
we will create a Tunisia window in the
Erasmus Plus program worth 10 million
euros to support student Exchange
we will establish a talent partnership
to give tunisia's youth opportunities to
work to study and to train in the
European Union so that they develop new
skills useful for modernizing tunisia's
economy
so there is a lot of work ahead of us I
have asked commissioner vahali to take
this work forward
and finally
we want to reinstate our association
Council
the high representative is ready to
organize the next meeting before the end
of the year
team Europe that is the commission and
the member states
are looking forward to work with our
partnership on our partnership with
Tunisia many things
well I do fully agree with what
president founder lion
just stated whom I want to thank very
much
for her tireless work
just five days as past have passed since
my visit to Tunisia and we have already
achieved an important goal
in this meeting with President Syed
together with Ursula and with Mark
whom I think to
also came about uh came about because of
the diplomatic work that Italy Italian
government has been done and I'm glad of
it it's very important for all of us
and we are very satisfied with the joint
Declaration of the European Union with
Tunisia
that was adopted today it is an
important first step towards creating a
true partnership with the European Union
that can address the migration crisis
but also development for both sides of
the Mediterranean in an integrated way
we have an important window of
opportunity between now and the European
Council at the end of the month
we must all continue to work hard to
achieve a memorandum between Europe and
Tunisia that can lay the foundation of a
new page
in the history between Europe and
Tunisia
and following this we are ready to host
an International Conference on migration
and development in Rome that we talked
about with President Sayed as a father's
step in this journey that we have
undertaken together and of course we
consider this work useful also to help
help Tunisia and its negotiations with
the ifm
for the framework agreement that remains
a priority for the stability and the
growth for the country
European
foreign
well thank you so much and and indeed uh
Ursula you did a lot in your team to
prepare for this
um and Georgia your visit last week has
been very successful and we are building
on all of this
uh and I think this was a very good
meeting and the meeting was very good
because we agreed on a broader gender
with Tunisia to discuss many issues over
the coming weeks and to implement all
the plans we have made
and yes that is about the economy and
also bilaterally
I mentioned to the president that the
Netherlands will send an economic
Mission as soon as possible to Tunisia
to discuss energy agriculture water
management and of course tourism
um and then to build on what we already
have bilaterally there is already
bilaterally uh a huge corporation going
on in the area of development Aid and
other bilateral
um uh biological issues we discuss and
on which we are working of course also
migration was on the agenda uh I think
we made some excellent agreements on
this and we will work on this over the
coming weeks and that is important
indeed also as Ursula mentioned ears to
kill that cynical business model of the
boat Smugglers
and migration is at this moment one of
the most important issues facing all of
us
um I was very happy with the European
agreement reached last Thursday in
Luxembourg between the 27 member states
and the European commission but of
course also the discussions now with
Tunisia are important and we can really
help each other and I fully agree with
the presidential European commission
that of course this all will be done in
full court in full cooperation but also
in full accordance with the human rights
so we have discussed this comprehensive
package and we will now work on this
over the coming weeks up to the European
Council at the end of June uh the window
is open and you we all sense that there
is this opportunity to really Foster
this relationship between the EU and
Tunisia and again let me say I found
these talks excellent today
and based on this a lot of work to be
done but I'm very hopeful that we
achieve our goals on all the issues
almost will work together thank you so
much
thank you
[Music]